what's going on inside you when you're
having a phobic reaction
in your brain recognize that this is a
dangerous situation
the hypothalamus triggers your
fight-or-flight response
and the hippocampus note of your fear
it'll remind you next time your
breathing gets quicker your
pulse speeds up you sweat your muscles
tense there's more glucose in your blood
increasing your energy
for most people the prefrontal cortex
the rational uniquely human part of
their brain
can calm the amygdala down but if you
have a phobia
that process doesn't quite work your
brain's constantly stuck in
tiger attack mode so where'd the phobias
come from
the first phobia in history belonged to
a man who was absolutely terrified of
flute music
but only at night this was described
2500 years ago by the greek father of
medicine
but hippocrates didn't use the word
phobia
this came 500 years later when the roman
author celsius
used it to describe a disease
hydrophobia
the fear of water which we now know as
rabies
celsius took the word phobia from the
greek god phobis
who was so terrifying that warriors
would paint his face in their shields to
scare their enemies
one of freud's most famous case studies
was a boy called little ham who
developed a terror of horses
after seeing one collapse in the street
freud
thought that this was really an
unconscious fear of his father
and related to sexual feelings for his
mother
modern psychoanalysts still believe that
phobias can be caused by secret internal
conflicts like this
another theory is that at least some
fears are innate
one study showed young infants images of
spiders and snakes
and found that their pupils dilated a
sign
of fear or intense focus
the theory is that fear of spiders and
snakes
gave us an evolutionary edge around five
percent of people
have these phobias and perhaps the same
mechanism left us with other common
phobias
a fear of heights darkness confined
spaces
all dangerous for we were evolving a
huge number of phobias have been spotted
and named since little hands
there's ayatrophobia the fear of doctors
begunophobia the fear of beards and
diphnophobia
fear of dinner conversation we may not
know the root cause of phobias
but we do know how they develop you can
catch a phobia by seeing other people's
fear
you can be tautophobia learning about
germs can lead to bacillophobia
or you can get a phobia by having a
traumatic experience
especially in childhood despite all that
common phobias are quite similar across
cultures
but one of the few that's culturally
specific is
taijin kuffuso the japanese phobia of
embarrassing other people
all the phobias have mentioned are
classed as simple phobias fear of
specific things
but there are two complex phobias
social phobia is triggered by being
around people you don't know
and agrophobia by being away from home
especially without escape routes
whilst these are serious conditions they
can be treated
with therapy and medication
simple phobias despite the suffering
they cause are easier to treat
the nhs recommends cognitive behavioral
therapy
with a therapist helping you to
gradually get used to whatever it is you
fear
so if a phobia is getting you down
why not pop in and see your doctor
unless of course you're a atrophobic
in which case it's probably better to
have a word to the nurse
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video